discuss his new documentary and all his
many trips to Ukraine during the war and
the ongoing conflict take a
look this whole story this whole movie I
was riveted to it and I wanted I'll tell
everybody I urge them to go see it it
doesn't matter what side of the Ukraine
conflict you're on it really doesn't um
how this came about is just a
fascinating set of circumstances where
you going over there to interview a guy
that's a former Entertainer that becomes
president of Ukraine and that was the
purpose of the interview the purpose of
the the intended documentary was a sort
of light-hearted take because it had
started pre-co and we had started
planning to do it long before this
Russian buildup of forces on the border
right and then it evolves into the
timing where you are
there as this conflict breaks out as
Putin invades a sovereign country
Ukraine you are right there and I I
guess what I came away with and I'm not
just to compliment you back because
let's be honest here if you and I get
into politics we're not going to agree
on a whole lot and I could talk about a
lot of your political positions in the
past and Hugo Chavez and stuff that dve
me up the wall but that's not that's
irrelevant to this discussion but you
were there and I came away with the
sense this is this is a real deal for
you you and and you proved it by staying
there in a war zone with the president
who's the top Target of let's be honest
here one of the world's you know a guy
that had no qualms killing innocent men
women and children bombing out
neighborhoods bombing out apartment
buildings you know ruining is in any way
could the the country of Ukraine
kidnapping 20,000 kids re-educating them
into hatred yeah and you were told by a
former National Security adviser uh
O'Brien to get the hell out of there
they were telling you don't stay there
because they knew zinsky was a top
Target but you stayed that tells me a
lot about you you didn't bail you could
have bailed out you have kids I'm sure
you don't want to die I'm sure you'd
like to live as long as you can I would
actually yeah all right why'd you
stay you know I I I'm having traveled in
places that certainly from the outside
uh um have a a certain narrative around
them of of of you know
unpredictability um I've had an anxious
moments at times and and
um this was very different in the sense
that they immediately uh there was just
a tremendous sense of
heartbreak and it didn't feel like it
was just for the Ukrainian people and
and Ukraine it really felt
like that that this would happen at this
point in human history it I thought
about my kids immediately that this was
something that would affect them and and
I think has and but but not anything
like what's happening on those front
lines and in that country to those
people but of course it's just
the the amount of um collateral damage
is is going to continue uh economically
I think as
psychosocially
and it's a real Tipping Point in terms
of how this country a country that I
love
also um are we going to hold on to the
great aspiration something I'm sure we
do share in terms of that the origin of
this country's ideal or are we going to
let it go and I think it's extremely
fragile right now you know we talked
about this the last time and I'm going
to give you news you probably don't want
to here but you probably also already
know is true conservative support in
this country for this conflict has
dropped
precipitously and we discussed some of
the reasons the the last time you were
here one is Europe has not stepped up
it's their continent and they needed to
do more from day one and incomes the
United States flooding Ukraine with
money you know basically a blank check
for a period of time time you know
culminating recently with $500 million
earmarked for green energy in Ukraine
that's the last thing that is important
in Ukraine right now green energy their
survival is the most important that's
that's so pisses off so many people in
this country we have veterans that are
homeless we have all these people we
that need help in our country and we get
we're spending money on green energy in
Ukraine that is asinine I think you'd
probably agree with that and here's the
other part so Europe's not doing their
part we're paying the bulk of of the
monies it's like a proxy war between us
and and Vladimir Putin which is what it
evolves into and Joe Biden did something
from the beginning that really
infuriated me and that was when he
vetoed the 28 migs I brought this up the
last time you weren't sure of it he did
veto it okay and I'm like here we go
again you know we start wars we
politicize them then we say never mind
and to you know tough luck to the people
that died in those Wars and left their
legs on the battlefield and Americans
have had it with that and they once they
once I saw that Joe was not into win he
should have allowed them to have the Mig
he if you're going to support a conflict
Europe has to go all in and you have to
fight a war to win a war and denying him
that Weaponry at that moment was
critical and it just infu iated me yeah
again I I'll say that I think there were
many elements at play um I I I don't
know to say that that that President
Biden wasn't the dominant voice in in
that I do know that later he did say um
he didn't feel that they needed them at
a certain point yep um
look I think that whether it's
Republican Democrat or anything in
between that and I'm of course not a
political analyst but as an observer of
it as one more citizen I would say that
I'm I'm I'm very confident that
whichever
party might support decisive action
complete action in this it would be a
political win not to mention a
principled one and by action I mean give
them everything they need now rather
than bit by bit over the time because
eventually there's not the political
will in this country to send US troops
there nor is there the desire of the
ukrainians to have US troops there in
fact pres in fact President zalinski
says very
passionately theyve fought too many wars
died in too many wars we don't want them
to fight
here so what we will do Republican or
Democrat over the long term is we're
going to give them everything it takes
short of US troops on the ground there
so we should do it now because the only
difference is death and destruction more
death and destruction
more separation longer separation of
families more psychological damage and
inevitably more that will come to our
Shores in terms of deficit and so I
would like to see you know I've never
voted Republican I'm unlikely ever to
vote Republican um you spent more time I
can help you the Democratic party um the
president
M um
look at this in a very realistic and
bold way and um and get this thing over
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else